jean paul dubois qui est journaliste
grand reporter au nouvel observateur
auteur d'un livre que j'aime bien que
j'aime bien que je sois droitier et qui
est intitulé les éloges du gaucher dans
un monde manchots qui paraît aux
éditions robert laffont écrits de quelle
main droite à droite il est gaucher
contrat et je n'avais pas d'autre
solution
donc vous étiez donner sens des gauchers
à oui ça irait médias et puis qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé ce qui arrive à 98% des
gauchers contrariés c'est à dire qu'on
aurait dû que avec plus ou moins de
bonheur pour en faire soit des bugs
soient des journalistes soient des
présentateurs de radio télé finition
avec des bonheurs divers mais vous
auriez pu vous servir avec un mais je
vous qui êtes amateur de football du
joug du pied gauche mon oeil de visée et
tenait gauche enfin je peux faire tout
le décompte de mai déconvenue oui alors
c'est par regret de ne pas appartenir à
cette minorité des gauchers d'avec chris
livre non c'est plus compliqué fixement
face c'est vrai il ya un moment sous les
eaux départ pourrait tout à fait france
c'est marty du nouvel observateur qui a
démarré cette affaire et quand quand le
journal a proposé sujet j'ai cru tomber
du ciel
ils ont quand je ferme huit feuillets là
dessus c'est pas possible ça y est ça
fait deux pages je dis jamais je vais
arriver à faire un truc pareil
et au bout du compte je n'ai fait 250 ou
240 et c'est venu tout seul c'est le
prototype du sujet apporte successives
vous à n'ouvrir
vous partez dès la vicodine négocié par
le b à ba de l'histoire et chaque fois
vous prenez des paliers d'écran et
chaque fois des portes s'ouvrent pour
accéder à l'est des trucs aussi
prétentieux que la philosophie
linguistique de l'histoire dira la
cybernétique dieu dieu et gauches et
droites ici bas dieu on sait va c'est
lui qui au départ a quand même mis la
pagaille c'est à dire c'est à dire il ya
un jour décrété droite droite bien
gauche mal et c'est à partir de ce
moment là que vous serez à ma droite les
a nuit ont commencé ce soir s'ils
voulaient si vous êtes dieu il ya les
brebis et les boucs
pourquoi parce qu'il est de droite et
une de gauche serrurerie et le choix
n'est pas innocent oui mais permet moi
je fais remarquer que pour le
téléspectateur
oui vous êtes vous êtes à la gauche est
remboursé c'est donc finalement là le
bon alors vous êtes je suis la droite du
père est là que je vais respecter pas là
vous êtes un malgré lui comme on disait
à shahar kim
vous êtes un art qui a requis 2 le harki
de latéralité oui sept non ça c'est pas
une blague
oui non mais je comprends parce que vous
avez le droit bon le droitier et n'être
cohérent le gaucher a sa cohérence et sa
particularité et vous avez une frange
seulement si pikine évident qu'ils
naviguent entre les deux qu'ils ont dit
qu'ils ne peut pas revenir en arrière
c'est quand vous êtes
gaucher contrarié ou plus jamais revenir
l'arrière et qui ne serait jamais quand
faux droitier chez les droitiers dont
vous êtes une frange facile mais on vous
sent finalement assez admiratif des
vrais gauche et de ceux qui le sont
restés
oui j'aime bien la gauche et tous mes
amis ensemble ah bon mais combien y at
il de gauche etc et la proportion je
crois que c'est un sur 10 1 sur 10 s'il
ya des gauchers ici alors évidemment on
les a on est sacré non c'est une
proportion qui à peu près à varier
abouti il avait pas dit on devine gauche
et quelques soient les cultures les
civilisations les périodes dans toutes
les races toutes les races et un gaucher
sur 10 ont tous des khaled en tout
terrasse ils ont pas de plein la tête et
partout partout ah oui donc c'est une
minorité qui est et qu'on est quand même
pas beaucoup alors pourquoi ne le sont
pas ce qu'apparemment les roues kg qui a
vu la ligue l'an dernier alors les
villes car on n'aime pas beaucoup les
rouquins non plus pourquoi devrait-on
pas le gaucher parce que toujours et
c'est là que l'interview dans ce parti
du lycée le le fait d'accoler et notion
morale à gauche et à droite c'est
toujours droite mali gauche bien et tout
fonctionne tout le monde fascinant c'est
ça l'air prétentieux de dire ça mais
quand on se penche vraiment à l'étude au
ras des pâquerettes de ces phénomènes
s'aperçoit que le monde fonctionne sur
un paramètre droite bien de gauche mal
que ce soit des parts est religieux de
convenance va cesser toutes tous les
sacrements sens oui mais alors sauf les
anglais ils roulent à gauche alors les
oui non mais justement les enlever
aucune particularité roule à gauche et
ils ont une boutique qui
cultive la particularité des gauchers
voyez une boutique on ne vend que des
absolument codé l'isolément des produits
objets des produits pour les gauchers
fonctionnement les orthodoxes font leur
signe de croix avec la main gauche
ah bah oui mais c'est l'exception qui
confirme la règle
oui alors maintenant ce qu'il montre
bien c'est que la main d'une dame qu'on
baise c'est la main droite le
on dit je le jure avec la main droite on
se signe de la main droite alors vous
quand vous étiez petit vous étiez lever
la région catholique et voir vous signé
de la main gauche commence alors on vous
tapez sur la toile là où les joueurs
c'est vrai moi j'ai été élevé de façon
tout à fait catholiques ont la plupart
des collégiens et quand j'allais à la
messe mère qui est une femme charmante
mais qui était sous le coup de l'époque
me disait gironde conduite le signe de
la main gauche serre toi de ta jolie
main c'est comme ça que commencer volé
un peu l'histoire sur toi de ta jolie
main certes ôté à la jolie ma salle à ma
droite
absolument oui bon et à l'armée déjà
j'étais réforme est bon avait été
réformé mais alors l'ailé gauche et
comment font-ils
cambrai l'ailé gauche est en dévers
probable à vous avez les gauchers soumis
qui s'adapte et qui ce qui s'est pris
aux locaux main et juin 2001 mais qui
est gaucher qui ne s'est jamais soumis
et qui est paref par réflexe je viens
pas pour revendre ces salué la main
gauche alors je sais auto autant avec
tam et le port à l'uniforme allemand
bon et puis c'est vrai que ce que vous
montrez bien c'est que la vie n'est pas
faite pour les gauchers et mais non mais
des choses toutes simples
par exemple le flipper et c'est vrai
j'avais jamais pensé que le malheureux
gauche et comme elle est toujours à
droite la balle
oui il est obligé de caisse quand il
fait la marque et la vie n est pas
vraiment fait pour les droitiers non
plus au flipper puis manière générale
ces noms c'est un jet d'encre rcm en
fait l'ailé gauche et c'est non il ya un
an mais le gaucher c'est vrai ne peut
jamais dansé la boule de savoie
directrice
oui c'est pas grave bon alors la
conduite la voiture tous les changements
de vitesse sont à briller quand vous
tentez vous tombe sous la main en
bretagne vous avez de le changement et
les pédales
c'est beaucoup plus pratique pour bouger
et à sa main sa main directrice est
beaucoup plus libre bon allez vous
parler aussi des vélos qu' il faut
intervertir les freins pour les classes
et le début des vrais en mer demande
quand vous prêtez votre vélo si le
droitier et un gaucher
parce que généralement il avertit les
freins ville interverti les freins
évidemment comme tout quand vous croyez
freiner avec le frein arrière ou freine
avec le froid avant la suite il ya une
scène très drôle euroteam s'il vous
raconter une scène à table où il ya un
droitier à gauche et alain à côté de
l'autre ces fréquences est très fréquent
puisque l'un de mes deux meilleurs amis
ça se reproduit tous les jours alors les
dimanches salma l'un et l'autre nous
mangeons seulement parce qu'ils se
contrarient il n'arrive pas on nous
invite d'ailleurs très peu mais vous
parlez c'est finalement sous d'autre
part un banquet de gauche et non pas du
tout sexy exit donc la ccss alors les
gauchers ceux d une minorité là qui se
réunit pour dire vrai on est ensemble on
est bien ensemble mais c'est une caste
ya réellement toute plaisanterie blague
mise à part il ya une caste je crois de
gauche et qui ne firent cc c'est pas pas
dire ça ressemble à quelque chose de
syndicales ou autre c'est ce sentiment
d'appartenance qui est qui et qui est
voilée comme ça et quand vous rencontrez
embaucher et que le divers gauche est
souhaité famille et moi j'ai une phrase
qui est extraordinaire qui m'a été dit
par de mes amis qui dit moi je pars
demain toujours en droitier est trop con
mais six ans gaucher se comporte mal je
ne mettrai jamais failli
vraiment il fait de l'ombre à la famille
bon c'est vrai ça est-ce que les
gauchers pour l'amour comme les autres
je pense je l'espère pour vous ah ben
non mais avec enquêter là dessus et j'ai
un crédit sur leur façon de dormir pas
la façon de faire mouche mais si je
pense que les bouchers doit avoir autant
de facilité que les droitiers et
gauchers pourparlers
à des gauchers contrariés avec o'shea
contrat et ça fait appel à beaucoup
d'autres paramètres qui doivent
déménager complique que singulièrement
la tâche
oui bon mais avouez que les gauchers
sont un formidable avantage c'est dans
sport et notamment au tennis on le sait
mcenroe et le conte épique au nord ce
sont des gauchers et on dit toujours
qu'ils ont un avantage sur les autres
la première fois ça proviendrait parce
que c'est l'heure c'est pas encore de
rien n'est encore définitif du phénomène
de l'inversion des hémisphères sur leye
your head dans le service faire fuir les
assaillants est même pas l'air mais je
sais que c'est dur d'expliquer ça des
fois chérioux moi même pas non c'est à
dire 'tiens des hémisphères et chaque
hémisphère dont contrôle pour l'un la
parole pour l'autre le geste est
le fait que pour le gaucher je suis sûr
de ne pas y arrive bon ben je renvoie
votre livre là-dessus bon je crois que
c'est valoriser le passage à vide et moi
ya une explication où il dit que les
mails tient debout
alors est-ce que vous qui connaissez
tout rejet car à timmins vous
connaissiez le gaucher célèbre saviez
salé gauche essaie d'aller gauche et il
est bien à quelques-uns oui ben oui il
ya par exemple paul newman
oui alors dans le village où il a joué
le film le gaucher mais il est gaucher
et d'ailleurs malheureusement il est
passé la semaine dernière soirée était
formidable qu'il avait passé soit et la
magie c'est dommage du juste après
apostrophe bon mais il y en a d'autres
qui donnent eux il ya toute une série de
joueurs de tennis
non non je m'appelle robes tennis
mondial non mais léonard-de-vinci n'est
pas le fils de le neveu de bach
luc-emmanuel était gaucher
oui mais il ya les plus beaux bernard de
vinci beethoven ne nous en avait en
catalogue wii violence a fait jouer des
deux manades de extraordinaire il y en a
deux qui sont fabuleux léonard de vinci
qui est le nord magnétique du gauche et
celui qu'on sort dans les salons parce
que sur les présentable et vous avez
lewis carroll qui lui car la grc
phénomène est un type qui était bègue à
la suite vraisemblablement hidalgo gbon
variés jlm contrariétés qui s'appelait
d'auxonne qui ait jamais pu prononcer
son nom correctement et qui invente et
un de ces personnages nous réseau qui
s'appelait dodo parce que de 2,2
d'auxonne ils pouvaient pas c'est devenu
dodo sibérie s'est racontée dans la
vidéo car il ya tout un nom il a écrit
un livre sur les miroirs à l'écriture
inversé c'est à dire vous écrivez à
l'envers de la main gauche et ce n'est
lisible que dans un léonard de vinci à
travers ce miroir
évidemment tout est à l'envers le temps
est à l'envers et un monde elle se fait
piquer alors la pique la reine la reine
pousse un cri elle est ensuite les
piquets et puis elle lui dit lui dit
j'ai besoin d'une servante et votre
salaire sera confiturière confusion
demain mais jamais confiture aujourd'hui
ça disent apprécierait ya des gauchers
catastrophique on avait cité assez
l'empereur tibère il ya des gauchers on
a des enfants romain gauche et où il y
en avait 2 mais surtout de tibère qui a
laissé des traces
c'était j'étais ok paradoxal car au fond
ce sinistre personnage divers sinistres
avec l'union autour de l'air et tout
pour réussir il était beau il était
grand et fort il est très intelligent
mais il est gaucher alors mais il était
gaucher et finalement il a tout raté
il a 2 il a tout gâché tout gauchy dans
sa vie mais il vit là vous voyez toutes
les forces qui l'avait il est devenu
soupçonne cruel tir sadique à la
française les gauchers c'était quand
même des ses caractéristiques il avait
une formidable main gauche solide avec
son agent il pouvait perçu une pub est
alors rejoint akka camarades il l'a tué
avec sa main gauche et il ya un autre
gaucher quand même célèbre qui n'ait pas
de faire commun c'est jacques
l'éventreur bon il ya un autre convoi
sur les écrans ces stars sticky gauche
et j'avais remarqué non les stars ce qui
est gaucher
mais vous courant ne l'a pas fait savoir
c'est regarder bon alors c'est vrai que
alors un petit reproche c'est que vous
ne parliez pas d'aider des gens qui ont
justement le pied gauche notamment
football un pied gauche magique comme on
dit à commencer par maradona et qui
semble à la vous auriez dû en parler je
sais bien je rejoue bien l'immense ne
serait ce que pour satisfaire votre
maradona est gaucher c'est pas évident
en sport c'est c'est évident sports
d'opposition c'est à dire lorsque vous
mettez face à face 2 à 2,2 en évitant
des situations d'urgence mais sport
collectif où il ya tellement de
paramètres qui entrent en jeu que
raisonnablement même pour vous faire
plaisir je n'ai pas pu parler de marc le
même nom mais par exemple deux boxeurs
c'est vrai le gaucher on dit a toujours
un avantage sur le truc le plus
significatif c'est la finale des fleuves
du champ du championnat de nom de death
crime à los angeles aux jeux olympiques
ringer où il y avait huit tireurs sur 8
qui était gaucher
donc là il ya un avantage s'il n'y a pas
un avantage mais aussi du sien signe qui
démontre bien que le le gaucher en
situation d'urgence et un esprit
doué d'une minoration un petit peu plus
court d'être une autre explication c'est
que comme malgré tout il y à un dos 1-1
gauche et sur 10 un footballeur survie à
boxer sur vis un tennisman sur dix est
gaucher ce qui fait que les droitiers
joue beaucoup plus souvent contre des
droitiers contre les gauchers bilan qui
sont surpris c'est ce que le phénomène
de rareté mais à 8 sur 8 ha statistiques
à 808 maintenant à 8 sur 8 parce que
justement ils sont arrivés original mais
tous les ans mais il ya beaucoup plus
d'un footballeur sur disque et qui est
gaucher dans une équipe souvent il ya là
même la moitié qui est oui mais il ya
une différence entre le quai et la main
avec le foie les autres enfin c'est une
minorité mais on peut pas dire que ce
soit une minorité quand même qui est
malheureuse
les malheureuses peut être au début si
on l'obligé si on enfin si comme vous on
vous oblige à devenir droitier pensez
pas que c'est que ça change maintenant
qu'on respecte le si je pense que de
toute façon il ya il ya un symptôme qui
est très net c'est que plus une société
vit souvent pire du sacré et plus le
gaucher a de latitude pour vivre plus
d'une société
se libéralise et plus le gaucher est de
l'attique une sas et ça se retrouve
toujours dans l'histoire
oui mais il est pour venir qu'il soit
malheureux il ya en fille il ya tout en
cours de phénomène qui fait que ce sont
des gens qui vivent une fois qu'ils ont
conscience de leur état critique parfois
dans je suis pas dans un monde qui n'est
pas le même le phénomène du miroir je
trouvais il est l'image qui rend le
mieux
mais vous êtes un peu youtube de vous
même car vous vous dites en 16 ou le
temps vous avez l'air de dire que les
gauchers sont obsédés je veux pas aperçu
les gauchers ne sont pas obsédés les
gauchers se reconnaissent entre eux et
les gauchers sont tous fiers d'être
gaucher alors contrarier les ja méfiait
le droit le lieu parce qu'il appartient
à une minorité
oui une vie tout à fait mais non mais je
retourne à votre question nous aussi son
malheureux ces appareils peuvent de
l'appareil n'ont pas forcément ils sont
ils sont gênés sont gênés ils sont gênés
dans leur travail parce que c'est pas
pratique
c'est pas pratique de 2,2 de vis et d'un
certain côté c'est pas pratique d'ouvrir
des quais de port viennent c'est la
ville d'auch prédit quand même la
révolte des gauchers mais ça va arriver
mais ça j'espère bien ah bon enfin car
une révolte des documents salue quand ça
ça vous pend au nez
devred ambidextre ça est juste
oui me paraît que c'est très dangereux
ben oui puisque les robinets star du
cerveau chez conduit à leur équilibre
psychologique de naître doit reposer sur
des polarités et il en mille extrait la
négation de ses priorités est dans la
négation de paramètres tels que le bien
le mal est tout autre sensation qui
passe par là je suis donc connaître en
misek str peut provoquer des dégâts
beaucoup plus dangereux que le gauchisme
et c'est vous la programmer pour quand
la révolte des gauchers disons la
seconde je pas la prochaine coupe du
monde de foot
[Musique]